[Music]
you better get married soon you you
start Angelou Oh
in his defense to its 30 and the actress
playing her is 40 my dad's been saying
that to me since I was 15
oh hi there narration fairy you're up
early as nice Greek girls are supposed
to do three things in life marry Greek
boys make Greek babies and feed everyone
until the day we die isn't that true
basically any conservative culture
replace Greek with Jewish and throw in a
couple songs and got Fiddler on the Roof
if we're going to get technical and I
intend to those fancy E's are actually
the Greek letter Sigma which translates
to an S so this actually reads My Big
Fat Greek Wedding why is working at your
family's restaurant considered such a
death sentence oh my immigrant family
owns three successful small businesses
sucks the other girls were blonde and
delicate and I was a swarthy
six-year-old with sideburns did she go
to some Aryan boarding school even if
the school had a diversity problem there
had to be one other non blonde at her
school
if Nik has one goat and Maria has nine
how soon will they marry hey we're just
under four minutes into the movie and
she's already culturally painting the
Greek people into a corner aren't you
gonna talk about next their inability to
handle finances I don't know a lot of
Greeks but this seems a little
heavy-handed imagine if the parents in
the fake movie my big fat Russian
wedding lived in a house that looked
like st. Basil's Cathedral also this
garage is the only thing that has ever
forced me to see the benefit in
homeowners associations my dad believed
in only two things that Greeks should
educate non-greeks about being Greek and
that any ailment from psoriasis to
poison ivy could be cured with Windex
okay maybe he does spray Windex on
everything but his priorities are way
skewed if one of his two only beliefs in
life is Windex based you should be proud
to be a great does he think about
anything else or is his brain just
filled with bouzouki music and people
throwing plates I'm all for being proud
of your heritage but he has to have some
personal hopes and dreams a couple more
years went by and my dad brought his
mother over from Greece to live with us
because we weren't weird enough there's
absolutely nothing we heard about an
adult child taking care of their aged
parent in fact it's like one of the most
honorable things a person can do how can
her little racist friends spin that one
those Greeks down the road take care of
their grandma how weird we just put ours
in a home and ignore we told my grandma
the war was over but she still slept
with a knife under her pillow huh
she has PTSD and is afraid of being
murdered what a crazy old lady my
brother
has two jobs to cook and to marry a
Greek virgin every Greek person can be
wholly described by two things that's
racist also aren't those basically the
same jobs that are expected of nice
Greek girls at least there's gender
parity if nagging was an Olympic sport
my aunt Voula would have a gold medal
and if on-the-nose expositional and
slightly sexist narration was a little
big sport you would have a gold medal my
sister married young and became a Greek
baby breeding machine in case you missed
it Greek women are just supposed to have
babies and nothing else if you're still
having trouble don't worry I'm sure
they'll mention it again Joey Fatone is
of course of Italian descent not Greek
that's racist
I'm not sure this comment juxtaposed
with her dad telling fifteen-year-old
Tula that she needs to get married
because she looks old is a sexism sin on
Greek culture or just this movie for our
purposes let's blame the movie - useless
to dream because nothing ever changes
losing all hope right before a glimmer
of hope cliche apparently this is the
first time a handsome man has ever
coming to the restaurant because she is
creep staring at him like a Middle Ages
time traveler who just saw shower for
the first time by establishing that he
doesn't see the big deal with blonde
chicks they're really just establishing
that his type is the opposite ladies
with dark skin and hair I bet his last
four girlfriends were Hispanic Mike has
terrible timing he invites Ian to meet
him at a restaurant but they only have
enough time to look at a Polaroid taken
at a party he went through the night
before this reminds us the 2002 even
though it doesn't seem like it was that
long ago is now a relic of the distant
past a computer I could go to college
courses Tula is making an effort to
improve their business but all he seemed
to latch on to was I could take some
college classes which means he's not a
good listener or his English isn't great
or both also doesn't her dad know that
colleges have a Greek system is the neck
what's the unmarried daughter the
appendix
so what force it needs more school she's
smart enough for a girl you think you're
smarter than me ah Maria didn't really
convince cus this was a good idea she
mostly just yell at him for that comment
about Tula being smart enough for a girl
while valid her outrage didn't really
accomplish anything I guess her dad is
just confused enough now Tula gets to go
to college to list going to college
montage depicts more of her giving
herself a makeover than her actually
learning about computers I understand
the parallel between this moment and the
moment with the blonde girls when she
was six but the maturity level of a
bunch of 25 to 30 year
is probably much higher than their
six-year-old counterparts making tools
transition to the popular table a lot
easier
I hope this class isn't just an
elaborate April Fool's joke Expedia will
make all this irrelevant your aunt will
go out of business in three years
April Fool's Oh me business is bad if we
were to zoom out next to Maria we would
see someone holding cue cards for voula
to read Wow it was really easy for
mister why do you want to leave me to
send his daughter to another business
thanks for holding contact lenses in one
computer class have also really boosted
her customer service skills Jane
Eastwood continues the tradition of
Eastwood's telling other races to get
off their loan okay
something should give before this
happens unless this is the strongest
grip a headset has ever had and the
phone is bolted to her desk I'm not
buying that this would bodyslam her to
the ground
- porky pocket the one dude she's been
horny over for months basically insults
her name just as much as the mean girls
used to do at school but she lets it
slide I know - also what the hell did
you guys talk about for five hours
behind her desk at the travel agency my
family owns that restaurant I remember
you character meets love interest free
makeover then has a chance with them
post makeover but character doesn't want
them to know who they are and love
interest remembers than anyway cliche
remember you can't tell two blond women
apart he doesn't notice from penis are
we sure II and doesn't have some kind of
rare face blindness does everyone look
like the Greendale human being to him to
us being so secretive about her
culturally proud and a little
rambunctious family if I worry and I
might start assuming something really
strange like their cult leaders or
people who watch The Big Bang Theory
montage to show they keep going on dates
but Ian still hasn't gotten laid an
alternate title of this movie could have
been the 30-year old virgin we can do it
right here in the car great excellent
cover doula she totally bought it but
really no she seemed to totally buy that
mother Mary Joseph almost halfway
through the movie and were so far away
from planning a Big Fat Greek Wedding
her mother's telling her to break up
with her boyfriend guy that parents set
up with her daughter is not appropriate
for anyone cliche actually this turns
into a whole unacceptable montage in
itself a cliche let's add five cents for
this bullshit
this man is clearly a sex criminal that
her father picked up off the street I
feel like the police are out looking for
it I guess if they're gonna keep nailing
stereotypes they had to nail the wasp
family also and they did Tula doesn't
respond what the hell is wrong with you
why would you ask me that while we're
both half-naked in bed could you imagine
telling the kids this story mom tell us
a story of how dad proposed well you
just finished going down on me
is he good boy I was the last guy you
brought home for to look good point
based on the way he was assaulting that
spoon probably not did you ever have a
class interrupted when a teacher's
girlfriend or boyfriend came by and
creepily stared into the room that was a
very romantic way of saying she gives
him boners skunk skunk is a totally
normal word that people in their 30s
should be comfortable with who's that
food for Nicky gonna be you've got mom
Nicky isn't going to be my godmother
also no I don't want to seem ignorant of
Greek Orthodox traditions but well I am
is this really the baptism kiddie pool
because this looks like a very nice
church it's the real one in the shop or
something I would imagine you would need
to attend the Greek Orthodox Church for
a little while to show signs that you're
practicing the faith before they would
baptize you I'm Greek now I guess as
soon as you become Greek you get all
oily that's actually really racist for
real can you make it look like an
accident I like me when I take out your
kidneys but get a kill yeah Tula's
brother and cousin tell Ian they are
going to kill him five times within 30
seconds
[Applause]
congratulations Ian this is one of the
few times a white guy is subjected to
that question for the wedding
Ian's mother should know the rule about
the bride's family plans the wedding
these two families definitely have their
differences but that rule was the same
for both the wasps and the Greeks but
you didn't have to bring it to the
in-laws house Ian's parents characters
are that they are white her dad is just
kind of a manipulative prick I don't
think this has anything to do with him
being Greek after he says this and
Tula's brother is slapped for telling E
in the wrong phrase Ian doesn't react
one way or another that he said
something that definitely wasn't Thanks
Maria not only decided to order wedding
invitations until no one for two weeks
but also thought the best place to store
them
in the kitchen cabinets because she was
waiting for someone to talk about
wedding invitations in the kitchen
creating an opportunity for the seamless
reveal at 30 she should be able to
anticipate things like this her family
doesn't stray too much from certain key
rules one of the big ones is the family
comes to all the things I know this and
I've only been watching them for an hour
did they not tell Ian's parents that
plans change from a quiet dinner to a
family barbecue they didn't look so
horrified at normal barbecue behavior
this party is being expensive to whole
Lambs plus sides this meal cost like
$1,000 Nick Nick Nick Nick Nick so
everyone in the family gets a normal
American eyes name except for Tula and
aunt Voula come on you never saw a bundt
cake in a supermarket were you even
aware you fell for it the first time
that's where we from
you like them I make them do these
actors get a paycheck for being extras
or did they even get day player status
if their characters were murdered the
detective would immediately close the
case for being too inconsequential
inside the law he found teeth and the
spinal column side the lung what's my
twin
I smell a spinoff My Big Fat Greek lump
Tula's family is a thousand times more
chill than Ian's pinched as parents I
don't know why people who live in
Chicago a city with one of the country's
highest Greek populations are so
perplexed by Greek food white parents
drinking montage is so obviously filler
to inflate the runtime you can see the
editors grudge marks on the print movie
makes it seem like this Greek family
went way way too far in trying to
impress Ian's parents but since his
parents didn't try at all maybe the
movie should stop to consider whether
they're worth trying to impress yeah I
had no idea yet so few friends oh that's
one of those jokes that's not really a
joke I mean according to this movie he
just has the one Borean no wonder he is
excited to have a big family my village
so many Wars Turkish German they all
made a mess they all made a mess is the
movies first understatement and it's
about Nazis we came here for you so you
could so you could live okay immigrant
parents are all
- once it did Maria coordinate this
history lesson or does grandma's
dementia give her excellent timing
we may be lambs in the kitchen Tigers in
the bedroom I am now imagining a lamb in
the kitchen being very ineffective is
this the movies third or fourth montage
I lost count
her entire bridal parties her family she
even has fewer friends than he Tula
didn't try on her wedding dress several
times and have several fittings before
the day of the wedding are the Millers
such huge assholes that no one wanted to
come to their son's wedding they've had
months of heads up on the fact their son
is getting married in a Greek Orthodox
Church 15 minutes of research before the
ceremony would have been a good idea I
was hoping we would make it through this
movie without hearing this but just
couldn't help yourselves also Ian's
parents just reveled in a joke that's
older than the color white itself to
explain something to Ian that they
should have gone over in the rehearsal
it's almost like she's not explaining
this to Ian but to me no one tell the
Greeks that a German wrote the wedding
march she wipes off her makeup then has
on the perfect amount of makeup there is
no way that's not a sex club and it
comes from the Greek word Mila
which is me well I know this is a
running gag but Miller comes from the
northern middle English term for
millkeeper but that would ruin his
touching analogy the whole apples and
oranges idiom pertains to two things
that are so different they can't be
compared which is quite different than
the way he took it which just goes to
show you if you have a character who
doesn't speak English very well no need
to spend time having his or her lines
make sense that's what we do the parents
they give a gift right that's very
different from other cultures where the
parents never give gifts bought us a
house let's not get too sappy to quit
Tula knows these people too well to not
immediately ask wait what's the catch
Ian's parents wait until the reception
to no longer be stuffy assholes maybe
this is what they're like after two
shots and we missed that during the
shots montage at the house and wherever
I go whatever I do they will always be
there
that's a mildly horrifying thought to
have just before your wedding night and
six years later it was our daughter's
turn to go to Greek school is there not
another Brownie troop in the Chicagoland
that she could join or another Greek
school just saying she could do both and
they live right next to her parents make
sure to check out the upcoming sequel My
Big Fat Greek Everybody Loves Raymond
also I tried to warn her she bragged it
again or his - his sister pulling a
Bonnie Swanson any ailment from
psoriasis to poison ivy could be cured
with Windex ever since cinemasins began
the most requested thing has been TV
since and now it's a reality click the
link in the description below to check
it out and now the audio outtakes and
leave space sometimes the space is so
big that the roof can't support itself
so it collapses here my brother George
she's wife Frieda and their children I
need to Diane and Nick the first time I
was introduced to all of them once it
was crazy
Paulie and his brothers had lots of sons
and nephews and almost all of them were
named Peter appalled mr. Bert collars
cheese drone nasty you kill my daughter
and I guess female
do you think anybody can see us down
here why I don't have sections can we